it's awesome to see this tiny little bee
doing something so massive so how is
this small be pulling this off or out
laughs what we're seeing here is a mason
bee and this is a solitary bee so not
one that you're going to find in a hive
or a colony with other bees and this
nail has been pushed right into this
little bees home insects are
fantastically strong for their size in a
strongman competition people can drag
things about twice their body mass
whereas this bee can drag something
thirty-five times its body mass and
that's not because of these muscles are
better than ours it's because of
something called the strength to weight
ratio as animals get larger they
actually have to use a greater and
greater proportion of their own muscle
mass to carry around their own bodies
now in something as tiny as the bee
we're seeing in this clip it's not
having to use a lot of its own muscle
mass to carry itself around and so it
can use a greater proportion to move
things like the massive nail we see in
this clip
and we think the be totally nailed that
task
you